at the funeral of a child in the city of
raphael in southern gaza
a woman in shock says only children
playing with their toys
mothers grandmothers and families left
inconsolable
innocent victims of days of heavy
israeli airstrikes and artillery fire
that destroyed homes and neighborhoods
what has this baby done we were sitting
safely at home
we didn't hear a warning rocket our
house got hit violently
why why why do they bomb houses in their
residence
in the northern baithanu neighborhood
people searched through rubble for their
belongings
gaza is home to about 2 million people
in an
enclave under israeli blockade there are
few places
to escape the bombs gaza is probably the
most densely populated spot
on earth it has been under 14 years of
air sea and land blockade
it is a place where despair is extremely
high
and where civilians are trapped
[Applause]
to escape the bombs many children are
sheltering in schools but they still
don't feel safe
we ran out of our house after the air
attacks and our house was bombed
we fled to the school and we were told
that the smoke from the bomb was
poisonous
we don't know what the poison is and we
only know that the thick smoke after the
explosion
was very choking for what purpose in the
united states on thursday house democrat
rashida taleb
made an emotional statement to congress
reading the words of a palestinian
mother
member of congress now i want to read
something a mother named
wrote two days ago she said quote
tonight i put the kids to sleep in our
bedroom
so that when we die we died together
as al jazeera spoke to amman about the
message it was interrupted as
bombs exploded nearby you can hear it
actually while we're speaking
there is uh loud sounds of bumping
gazan people are living terrifying
tonight
like every single day we wake up to
reply to messages like
are you alive and
we're scared every single night we say
that we are next
[Music]
hamas and its allies have responded to
the attacks by firing a barrage of
rockets from inside gaza
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu says the bombardment
will not end soon as bombs fall rescue
workers dig for survivors
after a house was hit in ashati refugee
camp on friday
killing 10 members of a family funerals
are taking place throughout gaza for
those killed which includes
dozens of children for those who survive
the bombs
they're now left traumatized and
terrified of further attacks
laura about and manly al jazeera